[Music]
right the ever confused confounded joe
biden's still stumbling toward the
Democratic nomination unable to even
explain his own plan to address the
virus outbreak this is worse every
second of every day take a look and in
order to avoid that those very high
numbers we have to do at least several
things one we have to depend on what the
president's going to do right now and
first of all he has to tell wait till
the cases before anything happens with
look the whole idea is he's got to get
in place things that were shortages of I
I didn't assist as I suggested that we
should have people in China at the
outset of this event and when it all
started and Luhan province any of you
understand that there's reaction plus
his take Democrats keep hearing the
chatter the chitter chatter well they
got a dump Biden for New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo where do I tell America
about his record on White House deputy
chief of staff Fox News contributor Karl
Rove Karl good to see you
alright I guess they Joe Biden says I'm
out
then they're gonna bypass Bernie and go
to Cuomo a New York hyper super Lib that
lets out criminals and has sanctuary
state the whole bit no no look look the
only way it's not going to the
Democratic nominee is not going to be
Joe Biden is if there's a catastrophe
involving Biden and even then they're
unlikely to turn to somebody outside the
crew that's run for the nomination so
look Cuomo was very sharp and very clear
and precise with his brother no way in
heck is he going to run for president or
want to be considered for president I
thought he was very clear on that and
this is a this is a fantasy and the
flirtation that people have with
replacing Joe Biden with Andrew Cuomo is
indicative of a bigger problem that the
Democrats have you saw it in the ABC
Washington Post poll came out on March
25th showed Biden in the lead 49 47 down
from a month earlier where he led 50 to
45
but the interesting thing is this of the
Biden supporters only 24% say they are
very enthusiastic about their choice
that's it that means that about 12% of
the electorate is very enthusiastic
about Biden among the Trump supporters
53% say they're very enthusiastic that's
about 26% of the electorate so better
than by a margin of two to one the
electorate is more enthusiastic about
Trump than it is about Biden that is no
problem if you're a Democrat I think
every Democrat needs to answer the
question did Donald Trump do the right
thing with the travel ban I think the
Democrats in Washington answer was it
was it atrocious what they did holding
up funding for hospitals and workers and
small and big businesses so they could
fund the Kennedy Center and National
Endowment for the Arts do they now
support open borders in sanctuary cities
and free healthcare for illegal
immigrants did it now front and center
yeah well and you talked about the
relief bill I mean they really do you
think that same-day voter registration
was a critical element in fighting the
coronavirus do you think that hundred
million dollars for National Public
Radio was was a critical you know they
wanted thirty five million dollars for
the Kennedy Center they ultimately gave
them twenty five and you know what the
net what the Kennedy Center proceeded to
do fire every member of the National
Symphony Orchestra saying we can't
afford to pay you any more it was meant
to keep them aboard for fighting for
that garbage they basically took their
middle finger and shoved it in the face
of every American worker every small big
business and every hospital worker that
needed that money and they delayed it
for over a week all right call thank you